Preparing.
Okay. I will post the link into the
chat.
Yes. You're bringing it up for me. I'll
put it here as well. Alright. Nice.
Alright. We'll get started in just a few
seconds.
Sure.
Alright. Welcome everyone.
Thank you for joining us today.
Today, I have the pleasure of being joined
by Matt.
Say hello, Matt. Hello.
We're gonna use today as a stream to
take a look at Matt's pretty cool setup
that he's got configured with Home Assistant
to provide loads of cool home automation.
And we're also gonna take a look at
some of the integrations with Home Assistant so
that we can see how InfluxDB
becomes a part of that setup.
And we'll try to kind of discuss
using my experience along with with maths to
see what else we could do with InfluxDB
to help improve that whole automation as well.
So I think I said any further ado,
what we'll do is we will hand over
to Matt. We'll take a look at what
he's got running.
I will try and probe him with some
questions. If you have any of your own,
please feel free to drop them into our
chat box, which I will be monitoring
and we will take it from there. Over
to you, Matt.
Right. Let's
get home assistant up on that one there.
So I kinda started with home assistant when
I realized, like, I had a lot of
home
sort of smart devices as you would call
them. I had some Philips Hue lights.
I had some sensors from other various other
companies. I had some basic
RF radio frequency switches,
which had timers built in for my reptiles.
We have two reptiles downstairs and one in
my office who needs light at different times
of day.
They have different lamps and different heating and
temperature and humidity requirements.
So I had a lot of non connected
devices for monitoring and measuring that sort of
thing, and we were having some trouble keeping
one of our reptiles at a correct humidity
level.
So the problem with that was that they
needed to be at a certain humidity level.
We were having trouble keeping the tank between
the right range. It would get too low
during the day.
You have to mist them and spray them
with water to keep it at the right
level.
So we bought a device that's just a
very basic timer device. A tank of water
sits on the side of his tank and
sprays water in every few hours for us
just to keep the humidity level up.
That's interesting.
But there's no way for me to monitor
that being a developer. I like everything to
be, you know, centralized and then want to
grab everything as as in one place if
possible. So I started looking at what was
available for me for actually
collecting that sort of data and
Home Assistant popped up because I had some
cameras as well. And I realized that actually
I was looking at one app for my
lights, one for my cameras.
I couldn't control switches with another because they
they didn't have an app for them. They
were just very basic devices.
So I looked at Home Assistant as a
way to get all of these separate ecosystems
talking to each other because typically they don't
do that.
Ecosystems are built by different companies. They might
use similar protocols,
but they each have their own gateway. They're
in implementation.
They don't typically like working together unless the
company decides that that's the thing they want
to do. So you're kind of at their
mercy if you want to get them talking
to each other.
So I I looked at Home Assistant as
a way to centralize it all. I can
now have one app
to monitor my switches, my lights, my temperatures
around the house for my reptiles as well
and control them
is where I started, you know, have buttons
for clicking and nice dashboards for everything.
And now I'm sort of in the stage
where I'm moving towards less control and more
automation.
I don't want to have to do some
of these things manually. It doesn't make sense
for me to do that. So I I
automate it as much as possible so that
I don't have to think about it and
it just does what I need to do.
So
Home Assistant itself is
it's four kind of key components under the
surface, the architecture of it. It's got an
event bus, which is like the heart the
heartbeat of Home Assistant.
You
have a state machine that stores the states
of various devices around your your sort of
platform or your home,
and that can emit state changed events into
the event bus. There's a timer that emits
emits a new event every second into the
event bus, so you can, you know, act
on a timer if you need to.
And there's a service registry that allows devices
and components and platforms and all the different
integrations that they that might exist. They can
register a service with the service registry that
can both
react to call service events when an event
happens that says, hey. Call this service and
perform this action. And then when it's done
that, it will
push an event back into the system to
say, hey. I called this service. So you
get an event saying, hey, light system. I'm
gonna call your service to turn this particular
light on. It will go into up turn
that light on, update the state of the
light, and then it will emit event back
into the system saying, hey. I've now called
that service, and the state machine will update
an event put an event into the event
bus and say, the state of this particular
device has also been updated.
So
from a development perspective, it's something that, you
know, a number of developers will be familiar
with. It's an event based system. You can
put events in. You can listen for events
and react to them. And that's a fairly
sort of, you know, widespread pattern in the
development world. So it made a lot of
sense for me when I looked at it
to say, actually, this this looks a lot
like some code I've written in the way
it works. I I've I've got a familiarity
with this. I'm not jumping into something and
not knowing what it is. On top of
that, a large part of it can be
configured through a UI, which is nice, but
also behind the scenes, it's YAML and Python.
So I can write Python scripts and execute
those as I want to. I can execute
command line scripts. I can configure stuff in
YAML.
It's a fairly friendly
way of doing it. It's still fairly techy.
I wouldn't expect someone without a background in
some technical capacity to get to grips with
it as fast, but I think that it
can be done because the UI has improved
recently that
a lot of it can be done without
actually having to dive under under the surface
and into code. You can just, you know,
click some UI options and it will and
it will work.
So what's really nice about Home Assistant is
it also provides a lot of developer tools.
So as a developer, I want to be
able to look at the event bus and
the state machine and the service registry and
sort of see what's what's happening with that.
I've got a number of different devices connected.
I've got devices from Philips Hue that are
based on Zigbee, but act through a Hue
gateway, which is a fairly common thing if
you've got Philips Hue lights. I now have
some sensors that are also Zigbee based sensors,
but they connect to a different gateway.
I have some IKEA
smart plugs, the the the trad free model.
They're also Zigbee,
they
connect to a different gateway.
So they're all the same sort of technology.
I'm generally sticking with Zigbee as a as
a technology
where possible,
but they all don't necessarily talk to each
other and that's kind of where Home Assistant
fits into the middle. It fits into that
section of, you know,
application and ecosystem one doesn't talk to application
or ecosystem two,
but they can both talk to Home Assistant,
and Home Assistant can delegate between the two
of them and and control them independently.
So with Home Assistant, I've got these sort
of various devices connected.
I have a number of in Home Assistant,
you have devices and entities.
So a device might be a
a switch. So that device will have a
state of on or off
or it could be a temperature sensor or
a humidity sensor so I've got one just
a little one here that say
it's an a Cara temperature and humidity sensor
So it will be one device, but within
this one device,
there are actually four separate entities. It will
tell me the temperature, the humidity,
the pressure,
as well as the battery level of that
particular device so I can monitor battery levels
and make sure that things aren't running out
of battery on me because Zigbee's a low
power system and a lot of the sort
of separate devices are battery powered, which is
nice because they can go anywhere, but you
need to make sure you're keeping track of
your
battery levels. Otherwise, things stop working.
So for example, with my reptiles, I have
some temperature and humidity sensors for mister Hubble,
which is one of my one of my
reptiles.
And I've got a sensor here
and it lives within the sensor domain.
And a domain in
Home Assistant is the type of device that
it is. So you'll have a sensor or
a
there will be a
switch domain for outlets and plugs that can
turn on and off. There's a light domain.
If you've got a binary sensor such as
a motion detector where it's either motion detected
or not, it's a binary state one or
zero, that will be a binary sensor.
And there's a whole range of different domains
that can exist with a home assistant. And
they're all referred to as the Internet of
things domains.
So it's kind of there's
dozens and dozens of them.
So here's a sensor
that is mister Hubble.
I can look at the historical data for
it so I can see that his temperature
currently is 25.2
degrees c which is about what I'd want
during the day that's nice to know I
can see the pattern of how it drops
overnight so at night it gets down to
around the 22 range which is you know,
about right as well sort of what I
want and then it starts climbing back up
in the morning when the lights turn back
on
and those lights are controlled through what's known
in Home Assistant as an automation
and automation is effectively a trigger and an
action with some optional conditions So you can
say the trigger is when this thing happens,
and that could be when the state changes
to a certain value. It could be
when an event is fired into the event
bus. It could be when a time is
reached, you know, at a certain point of
day, trigger this action.
A condition will sort of give you additional
things to say, you know what? I want
you to turn for example, my landing light
is on a motion sensor.
So I want you to turn the light
on when you detect motion,
but only do that after 09:00 in the
evening and before 07:00 in the morning, say.
So I can have these triggers that are
acted on conditionally,
and then they perform an action, and the
action would be turn this particular light on.
So
automations are configurable through a UI, which is
quite nice. I've got a number of automations
here to do various different things.
For example, if I look at my
search for landing light,
so turn on landing lights when motion detected.
At the minute, I've just got it sent
us up as a basic. When my binary
sensor of my landing motion sensor reaches the
on state,
then I want you to trigger an action.
So this is the trigger,
and the action is
it has a different number of things. You
can specify the type of action, so I
could also call a service. I could say,
when you detect motion, call the service and
send a notification to my phone to say
that you've detected some motion.
But in this case, I've got actually, I
want to activate the landing light and I
want to turn on the light level and
set the brightness to 10% because in the
middle of the night when I get up
and go to the toilet or, you know,
downstairs for a glass of water, I don't
want to be blinded by the lights turning
on at full brightness when it's dark because
I've had that before when I forgot to
configure it and it was not a pleasant
experience the first time that happened
so you live and learn and
then I've got a counter sort of automation
to that that says turn off the landing
lights when no motion is detected and what
that says is when the boat the binary
motion sensor
reaches
the off state for five minutes so I
don't want it to turn the lights off
as soon as it detects no motion because
that could happen a few seconds later and
it will be turning the lights on and
off repeatedly.
So after five minutes, if you haven't detected
motion,
then similarly
activate the landing light and turn it off.
So this kind of goes down to the
root of I'm now automating things that previously
I might have had a button for, you
know, I could have had a switch that
says turn the landing light on for 10%,
but I'd have to remember to press it
if I'm tired at the night, I don't
want to do that and it's the sort
of thing that can be automated to where
you don't have to think about it anymore.
So automations can pretty much do anything you
want.
We've got automations for buttons. So I've got
a button here. And when I press it,
I can have an automation run when this
particular event is detected.
I've gone down the route of configuring automations
for things like this weird little cube,
and this little cube emits events when you
change the side of the cube. So if
I change it from one side to another,
it will emit an event that I can
listen for and do something with. I've currently
got it configured to change the scene of
lights in my office so that when I
turn it to a certain side, the lights
in my office change.
It's completely pointless, but it's really cool and
isn't that what development is all about.
So I kind of figured that's that's a
way to do something interesting with something that
people might not be familiar with.
And I've got things like
mister Hubble needs a certain
temperature.
So if he gets too hot, I've got
an automation that says so he's got a
sensor of his temperature sensor and if it
gets above 30 degrees I want you to
notify my phone
that
his temperature is too hot
I might also then set it up eventually.
It hasn't reached 30 degrees, but I might
set it up to turn off his heating
lamp if it reaches 30 degrees because it's
clearly too hot and it doesn't need to
be.
But for now, he's never actually reached 30
degrees. This would be like a don't want
it to be there for more than, you
know, half an hour. So this is a
do something about it, but it's never reached
that level yet. So this is just a
you know, in case of emergency, let me
know that something something needs doing.
So this is kind of the core of
it. It's it's basically just different configurations of
when this happens, take this action and do
this other thing.
For me, it's it's kind of a bit
like Lego. You've got this core set of
Lego blocks, and it's kind of up to
you how you assemble them. You could do
something as simple as when a button is
pressed,
turn on a light. Or you could say,
when a button is pressed and this other
sensor is at this particular state, then alert
this device, turn on that light, play this
media over here, for example.
I have one set up for my doorbell.
My doorbell is a Zigbee button that when
you press it, broadcasts the doorbell sound through
my Google Home systems and then sends a
notification to my phone to tell me that
someone's at the door. And the reason I
put that in place was because I'm upstairs
at the back of my house in my
office, often wearing headphones when I'm working and
if the doorbell goes, never hear it.
So I needed something to kind of alert
me that, hey, someone's at the door. I
could potentially have it also trigger camera recording
because I've got a camera that looks over
our driveway. So I could say, you know,
when someone presses the doorbell, tell me that
someone's at the door, record a video,
and install that on my server somewhere.
And it's
kind of up to you what what you
want to do with it, and that's the
that's the flexibility and the freedom of Home
Assistant.
It's also part of the downside in that
you do have to configure everything yourself.
Previously, when I've used systems like Philips Hue
and whatnot, there's nice apps that you can
go in. You know, they're very generally pretty
slick.
They've got a lot of stuff built in
where you can just click a few buttons
and it will set something up.
But the problem with that is that then
you're limited to what they want you to
do.
With this, if it doesn't do what I
want it to do, I can probably write
some Python to get it to do that
for me under the surface. And I've actually
written a couple of custom Python scripts that
allow me to interact with my cameras to
turn on and off motion detection
because that wasn't something that was built in.
So I wrote a Python script that will
pause the camera response to tell me whether
or not motion detection is on or off
so I can detect that in a sensor
and have a look at it. And then
I've also got
a very basic script that just talks to
the camera URL
to update the
motion detection settings to turn motion detection on.
So it's kind of flexible, and that's what
I like about it.
So as a as an example,
we've got this event bus and that's kind
of the core of Home Assistant.
The Home Assistant developer documentation has got a
lot of diagrams and things around the architecture,
which is pretty good because they they like
describing it. It's it's an open source
platform built by developers.
They're they're very good into
in diving into the documentation on how to
configure things.
And even the YAML configuration for a lot
of the actual
integrations and things, it will give you all
the parameters and then give you some examples
of how you can use it, which I
always appreciate.
Because examples are kind of how I like
learning. I like seeing what okay. What's the
code I need to put in place to
get this to work? It might not be
perfect, but I can adjust it rather than
just saying, here's all the configuration keys, go
and work it out for yourself like some
documentation does.
So when I'm looking at my
my configuration file,
it's mostly just YAML. You can include separate
files,
so I can group lights together in this
groups file. I can configure InfluxDB integration with
this, you you know, database username and password,
and there's a separate add on that runs
InfluxDB for me. So the add on
setup
and runs InfluxDB,
the database itself. And then this integration is
just how Home Assistant knows how to talk
to it, which is nice because it then
means that I can potentially talk to different
ones. And I know that you found, David,
that
someone had put in a commit for InfluxDB
version two support recently.
So at some point soon, hopefully, that will
be in place and we can talk to
the InfluxDB cloud, which will be nice because
that means we can get a whole bunch
of new benefits that might not be supported
by the add on yet,
which is something that I
know isn't supported by the add on because
that's still running an older version of InfluxDB.
But with all this yaml, you can like
you say, you can configure kind of what
you want to do. So if I look
into my groups file, for example, I have
or my lights file even.
I've grouped some lights together. So I've got
each of my living room lights
are separate lights, but if I group them
together under the name of living room lights,
I can now control them with Home Assistant
as if they were one single entity. So
I can say turn on the living room
lights,
and they will act on all of those
lights within that group as if they were
one. I don't have to go through and
do it for each each of the lights
within there, which, for example, in my office
when I have seven lights in here would
be a bit of a pain to have
to go through and update each one of
them every single time.
So I've got them just grouped together as
a single entity.
So like I say, we've got this event
system that's the core of
core of Home Assistant.
And this particular switch, for example,
is connected through a gateway known as DCONS,
and it's a piece of software
and a piece of hardware called a con
b two,
which is a little Zigbee gateway that's plugged
into the USB port on my Raspberry Pi
that runs Home Assistant.
What that then allows me to do is
connect Zigbee devices to that gateway and then
listen to events from that gateway
whenever something happens. So I can listen to
events if I filter
these by decons event and start listening for
any decons events that come through if I
click this button I will get an event
that appears that says
what the event type is I've got a
decons event what the data of that particular
event is so I get the ID of
the device that it came from and I've
named this stream switch
unique ID
here and an event code Now the event
code can change depending on what happened.
So I we also get the time that
it was fired down to, you know, microseconds
level. So we get very, very high accuracy
on that if if if that's something that
you needed.
Now the nice part about this is that
this particular switch can emit multiple different events.
If I single press it, I get event
1002.
If I double press it,
I get event 1,004.
And if I press and hold it, I
get event 1,001
when I press it and event 1,003
when I release the switch.
So there's potentially four different events that I
can react on here.
In reality, it's only really three because press
and down. Press and hold, you get two
events for one for down and one for
up. But that could be used for something
like a when I press it and hold
it down, start recording something, and when it
releases, stop recording if you really want periodic
measurements or periodic
events happening.
But what that allows me to do is
I can listen for that particular event, and
now I can act on it and
run pretty much whatever I want.
So I've got this magic little light here.
This is a Philips Hue Go. It's a
Hue controlled Zigbee light bulb.
It's a little bowl. It's rechargeable.
It lasts a couple of hours on battery,
and it can also be plugged in. And
I usually have this up on a bookshelf
in my office for some accent lighting because
I'm a nerd and I like having all
that sort of lighting all over my office.
So
with kind of these two devices, I can
now get this button to do something with
this light. And for the purposes of this
sort of quick demo here, I'm basically going
to say, when this button is pressed, flash
this light.
And and that's pretty much all we're gonna
do. But configuring that is actually really quite
simple once you've got into it. So once
once I've worked out that the event for
pressing this button is event 1,002
on my stream switch,
I can go to my automation system,
and I can say click a little plus
button down here to say create me a
new automation.
And I've got some automations here, and they've
built this almond system, which is like a
voice assistant that can try and guess what
it is you're trying to do. You can
type out what you think it would you
would like it to do, and it will
try and put the automation together for you
automatically.
In reality, I haven't had a lot of
luck with that, so I tend to skip
past it and just go straight to the
creation of it myself.
So I'm gonna give this automation a name
and this is
when the stream switch is pressed,
flash the bowl light.
And that's the name we're gonna give this.
So the trigger type for this is an
event because I know I'm listening for a
stream switch event,
and it's gonna be event 1,002.
So I say the event the trigger type
is an event, and the event type is
a decons event because that's the platform that's
running this system, and that's the type of
event that I'm listening to.
Now this is just YAML in here, so
I'm just gonna paste in what I had
before.
But the data I'm looking for is
I'm looking for an ID of stream switch
and an event of 1,002. And if an
event a decon's event comes through with this
data inside it, that will trigger this particular
automation.
And what that allows me to then do
is say, right, I'm going to do something
with a device.
So the device I'm going to do is
my bookshelf
go is what it's called because these are
the Hugo lights.
I'd probably need to remade it to bold
because that's what I refer to them as.
But this is the light we're going to
be working with. And the action here I
can specify, I can either turn it on,
turn it off. I can toggle it. So
if it's on, it will turn off. And
if it's off, it will turn on. I
can increase the brightness. I can decrease the
brightness or I can flash it. And in
this case, we're going to flash it.
And what that will then do is that
will say, right, when this device is when
this button is pressed,
an event will get put into the event
bus. It will then this automation is then
listening for that particular event. And when it
does that, it will say to the event
bus, hey, I'm gonna put an event into
you that says you need to call the
light service on this particular light, and you
need to flash that light. And that's what
will happen is it will go into the
the event bus, put an event in, the
service registry will be listening for one of
those, that service, the light service will pick
it up, pull the the event out, say,
ah, I need to flash that light for
you, and it will flash the light for
me.
So once we've saved this, in theory, now
all I've done is I've put some YAML
in.
Behind the scenes, this action down here is
also just YAML. We can specify the device
IDs, the domains,
the entities, the type of thing we're doing
with it. So you can still edit YAML
if that's something you want to do. But
ultimately, you can just configure it through the
UI for the most part. So now this
is set up. In theory,
when I press this button, this light should
flash
and it's not.
So
the joys of all live demos, let's see
if we can work out what's happening.
So if I go back into my event
system and I start listening for decon's events,
if I listen for this particular event,
I'm still getting stream switch 1,002.
And I've pressed it and the light has
now flashed. What's probably happened there is when
you save an automation, you need to reload
the automation system within Home Assistant. If you
do it through the UI, it does that
automatically for you, but it can take thirty
seconds to a minute to do that for
you. So I think actually what was happening
is the automation system was just reloading in
the background. So if I press this button,
this light now flashes.
I can press it again, it flashes again,
I can press it again and it will
continue flashing.
So
automations in Home Assistant can be as simple
as, you know, click a button and flash
a light, or they can be much more
complicated in
in sort of, you know, actions that they
perform. I have one set up so that
when we leave home, it will turn off
all the lights for me, because my fiance
gets really annoyed that I leave the lights
on all the time.
They're LED lights, they don't use a lot
of power, but, you know, need to turn
them off when when we leave the house
and I'm a nightmare for leaving them on.
So we've got the Home Assistant app installed
on both of our phones, which has location
tracking,
and it can update my Home Assistant installation
to say, right, Matt and his fiance have
left home.
And then my automation runs to say, ah,
they've both left home. Therefore, I need to
go through and turn off all the lights
because they don't need them anymore.
So it can be as complicated as
location based tracking with
conditions and turning multiple devices off or
add this button, press this button and flash
a light.
That's kind of
at a basic level
what Home Assistant can do. There's a whole
community of add ons and plugins
and
systems that you might want to integrate with.
For example,
I've installed the InfluxDB add on through an
add on store. So I can go into
an add on store, click some buttons,
and a developer somewhere has set up a
repository that allows it to run an InfluxDB
container in the background.
And I've not had to do any management
of Docker on that. I can click a
button through a nice UI.
I could restart the service. I can stop
it. I could
I can configure it all through a nice
UI without having to manage it under the
surface. And that's kind of one of the
things I like about this is that I
wanted a bit more control,
but I have friends that run Home Assistant
in, you know, manually managed Docker
setups.
And I didn't quite want that level of
responsibility in managing my platform. I kind of
wanted to
put a memory card into a Raspberry Pi
connected to my network and just have it
work. And that's how I've installed Home Assistant.
And for the most part, that's how it's
working so far. And I'm quite happy with
that. But if you wanna get, you know,
down into it, you can run your own
Docker containers. You can run.
It runs in Python, so you can run
core
the core application itself
any way you want that can run Python
for the most part.
I personally just wasn't
happy to do that sort of thing because
I didn't want to spend the time doing
it.
And I didn't I didn't really realize that
actually I don't need to do that because
I don't think I'm gonna I would use
any advanced functionality of that. So I've not
I've not bothered. And so far, it's worked
out okay.
Nice.
So I have
I kinda one question that's popped in my
head right now is that Yeah. Obviously, I
wanna get this up and running on my
house now. I think Home Assistant seems pretty
cool.
So I install it on I've got a
a micro server
in the corner.
I get the containers running
and I go out and buy a new
hue bulb.
How do I add that to Home Assistant?
Right. So the way devices are added, it
it kinda depends on what platform you're using.
So if I go to my integrations, it
will show me all of the different integrations
I've got running for
various different devices.
So with Philips Hue,
you could connect it to any Zigbee gateway,
I believe. I think because they're Zigbee, they
can work with any gateway, but you can
also connect them to the Hue hub. So
the way Hue works is you buy, like,
a little home hub, and that's what you
set up and connect to your network.
And the app talks to the hub, and
the hub deals with the Zigbee network between
all of the other devices.
If I add a new device to that
hub, it and I've previously configured Philips Hue
for Home Assistant, it will automatically add it
as a new bulb within Home Assistant for
me.
When you first set up Home Assistant,
it's a really nice way it works is
it sets itself up. And then the first
thing it does is it says, hey, I've
discovered these various different devices and integrations on
your network. So mine said, hey, I can
see your router and I can give you
some stats for your router for your traffic
in and out if you want. I can
see that you've got a Google Chromecast on
your TV.
I can see that you've got Philips Hue
lights,
and it kind of said, hey. All of
these things need to be connected to me,
but I've discovered they're here. Here's how to
go and do it, and you click the
button on Home Assistant that says, I'm gonna
connect you to Philips Hue, and the Philips
Hue gateway says, hey. You need to press
the button on me to authorize this like
you would with most other devices with Philips
Hue. And what that then allows me to
do
is have it work by just connecting my
device to the Philips Hue gateway, at which
point it will automatically add entities into Home
Assistant for me.
So this is the the option here, enable
newly added entities. So when it's if it's
disabled,
entities for Philips Hue will not be added
to Home Assistant. So you can set it
up so that it doesn't automatically add things
to Home Assistant for you, and you have
to go and do that yourself.
But I've set mine up to say, if
I connect something to Philips Hue, I probably
want it in my Home Assistant system. So
anytime a device is added to Philips Hue,
automatically add it to Home Assistant for me,
and it will be available for me to
use as soon as it updates. It could
be a couple of minutes,
but typically, it will it will add it
to Home Assistant within, you know, five minutes
is typically what I found.
Usually, a lot lot sooner.
But for the most part, it just
it's a weird thing to say, you know,
when it just works. It's a bit like
magic sometimes. But
the auto discovery stuff is usually quite good.
It's got integrations for so many things. Like
I said, I've got I've got a Raspberry
Pi running, my Pi hole ad blocking system,
and I've set up an API key for
that. And Home Assistant can talk to it
and tell me the percentage of ads that
it's blocked for me today.
As well as now having an API key,
I've got a button that I can press
that will disable ad blocking for me for
five minutes.
So my other half, my fiance,
she does a lot of sewing and crafting
and stuff, and there's been some fabric websites
that she buys fabric from that have been
blocked by pie hole because for whatever reason
it believes that they are
blacklisted domains. When in reality, they're not. They're
just a fabric website.
But she she's not gonna necessarily know how
to go into pie hole and configure the
allow list to put that domain on and
allow it through. So I I've set up
a a button and also Google Home Assistant
can do it Google Home can do it
where you can say, you know, okay, Google,
turn off ad blocking and it will disable
ad blocking for five minutes for me.
So I can turn off that sort of
thing as well if I were to need
it.
We've got things like the the mobile apps.
You can see I've got it on an
iPad, my fiance's phone, my phone.
I've got Font Awesome integrated into Home Assistant
as well because someone built an integration for
that so that I can use different icons.
When I first set it up because it
was based on the reptiles, I was really
annoyed to find that the default icon set
for Home Assistant didn't have a reptile in
it. So I was like, well, this this
this won't do.
And typical developer fashion, I went, oh, someone
else has done it for And they've put
full awesome in so I can have different
icons for things. For example, on my dashboard
here,
I've got my home and my dragon
and my office and my cameras. So if
I click on my dragon, I can see
that this is all the status of my
reptiles. So I can see their temperature and
their humidity is where where relevant
and keep track of their their statuses as
well as the insects that we're keeping as
well.
So
adding devices is fairly simple
If you've got like a Hue gateway.
For something like this, which is a button
that uses the con b two integration,
it's slightly different because that's a third party
Zigbee gateway and it's it's a bit more
of work to get involved. But what you
do is you install the add on for
it and then I can go into my
Deacons
integration.
I can go into my
h a con b device. It's just my
Home Assistant Con b gateway effectively that I've
named this connected to my Raspberry Pi.
I can put in my password,
and I can say
within here,
I've got all my lights connected. So this
with
IKEA trade free, the control outlets,
the little, like, UK plug socket plugs that
are Zigbee enabled and can turn
mains powered devices on and off. They come
they come as lights. They that's what they
count as. But then I've got my switches,
which are my little buttons for my bedside
switch and my office and my doorbell,
and then my sensors as well for my
temperature and humidity and my motion sensing. And
if I wanted to add a new device
for this or a sensor, you click this
little button that says add new sensor. What
type is it? So I typically mine are
other because I'm using the Xiaomi Aqara sensors.
And then it will effectively say, right. I'm
now looking for new devices for three minutes.
And you press the pairing button on the
device, it will appear here and you can
say, cool. Connected. Connect this device to me
and it's then paired to your gateway and
it will just then within a few minutes
be available within Home Assistant as well to
use.
So depending on what device you're using can
depend on how to configure it, but for
the most part, it's not too bad. I
haven't found it
problematic in any way. The biggest one was
just, you know, these can take some time.
If I'm adding, you know, eight of these,
it can take me ten minutes because I've
gotta sit and press one and then wait
for the next one.
But I don't know of any way that
they would solve that because that's gonna be
the case no matter what ecosystem you're using.
Okay. Perfect.
Very cool setup.
So these little graphs we've got here, they're
not being delivered by InfluxDB.
Is that correct? Not currently. No. These are
these are custom graphs. They look at the
historical date. And the reason they're there is
because I was looking through, for example, this
sensor and this is the raw data. This
is just every new plot is a is
a raw data. And I could get this
to display,
but in my shallow nature, I decided I
didn't like the way this looked
and so I wanted something different. So I
found there's a different card. It's a custom
UI component
and what it allows me to do is
specify color thresholds. So I can say that
when the color is either too high or
too low sorry. The value is either too
high or too low, then change the color
for me
as well as telling it how many points
per hour I want. So now it's doing
one point every two hours. But if I
specify four, I get a much more
accurate graph of up to date data because
I can specify a lot more points per
hour if I require that.
So I can I kind of just wanted
something that I could see at a glance?
I I had previously used Grafana and InfluxDB
because
all of my data is being sent into
InfluxDB and Home Assistant. Every state change gets
put into InfluxDB,
and that's just part of the in the
integration that Home Assistant can have with it.
I was using Grafana to actually display the
graphs as well,
but that's a limitation with Grafana is that
within Home Assistant, it has to be if
I want a card like this that just
displays it at a glance,
it had to be embedded via an iframe,
and that then meant that it was a
locally
referenced iframe. And when I tried to access
it remotely, it wouldn't load because it couldn't
resolve the homeassistant.local
domain name. And I had some issues that
I was I sort of said, you know
what? I don't think that's gonna quite work
for me just yet, so I will I
will leave it be.
But I am still running InfluxDB and it's
just hovering up all the data in my
system currently.
Shall we take a look at that?
Sure. Yeah.
So within InfluxDB,
Home Assistant kind of pushes stuff to it
however it it wants really. So I've I've
got it set up using the auto gen
retention period.
And the measurement is a percentage, for example,
for a humidity sensor. So the humidity sensor
for mister Hubble,
I want to look at the value and
it's within the percentage measurement.
This is kind of the query over the
last twenty four hours. So I can kinda
see that, ah, at its peak, it was
about, you know, 74
ish percent.
And on its lowest, it's just below 60%,
which for me, I can kinda look at
that and go, you know what? That's that's
about right. Mister Hubble wants between 6080%
humidity,
so I'm keeping that within an acceptable range.
Outside of that, it's not gonna do him
too much damage as long as it's not
dropping too low for too long.
But within this range, I can see that
this is a this is an acceptable
period.
The thing that I'm looking at eventually doing,
which is something that we've kind of discussed
with the InfluxDB two stuff is being able
to look at what the average humidity at
night is versus during the day. Because when
I've looked at his graphs in the past,
I've noticed that at night,
his humidity goes up because there's not as
much light reducing and heat reducing the humidity
within the tank. So I I was just
sort of really curious to see, like, okay.
Between
eight eight 8PM and 7AM,
what does the average humidity look like versus
7AM to 8PM during the day? Because then
I could kinda look
at, at night his humidity goes up by,
I don't know, it might be 10%.
I I honestly couldn't tell you.
But that then could then could potentially give
me some more insights into how I might
want to control his humidity his misting system
to keep the humidity up. Maybe I reduce
the frequency at night because that will be
better.
I could set it up to be sensor
based, but at the minute, it's just a
it's a device that's got a timer built
onto it. It's not actually connected to any
of my home automation stuff because we haven't
sort of looked at that as an option
yet.
But, yes, similarly, if I want to look
at the the temperatures for someone like mister
Hubble, I can go to the degree c
measurement,
look at the entity ID of Hubble temperature,
and I can see that over the past
twenty four hours, he's had a maximum temperature
of 26.2
and a low temperature of 21.8,
which to me, again, is about right. That's
what we're looking for when we're keeping reptiles.
So it's typically the you know, looking at
this sort of thing. I'm looking at it
going, yeah, it's acceptable ranges.
And, yeah, InfluxDB has just been hovering up
the data for me, which has been nice
because I didn't have to do it all
for lot to get it working. I installed
the I installed the add on, which set
up InfluxDB for me. I set up a
user, a database, and a password, and then
I configured it in my integration and Home
Assistant just over it. Yep. I'll do that.
And it's been submitting all the data to
InfluxDB in the background ever since, really.
Nice. Yeah.
Okay. So why don't we talk about the
problems we had?
So we got discussed the query that Matt
wanted to run on his data.
Now, I I guess what's important here is
that the add on that you're using only
deploys InfluxDB
one. Yes. Correct. It's not deploying InfluxDB two.
Now
it would be very difficult using InfluxQL,
which is a query language for InfluxDB one
to do
that kind of breaking down the values by
error and did aggregates across that specific window.
However, with our new query language within FluxDB
two,
that actually is
possible.
And we did try to do that through
the flux add on for InfluxDB one, but
we did have a couple of problems. As
we can see right now,
we have the flux script bottom and center,
but when we try to run it, we
were hitting a runtime error. Now there are
two reasons I think for this.
The first one is is that this is
running on a 32 bit r m b
seven Raspberry Pi.
And unfortunately,
flux does have some outstanding bug reports
that are affected with the 32 bit build.
And secondly,
as there as some performance improvements or challenges
right now with flux, that means that when
you run things like an accurate window or
calculate a mean over a window, is all
those values have to fit in memory.
And then the Raspberry Pi is obviously limited
access to memory depending on what else is
being consumed by other components on the system.
So
my other plan after that was, well, why
don't we publish this data to InfluxDB to
cloud? And it looks to be to cloud
actually has a very, very good free tier.
I don't think this use case would go
over, meaning that you could push that data
to cloud and then do all of your
more sophisticated flex based queries there.
However, in fact, if you don't mind, Matt,
I will just take over the screen now.
Sure. Go for it.
And we'll take that one.
You see my screen okay? Yep. Awesome.
Okay. So
my plan was we could just have this
rate to InfluxDB two in the cloud as
well using that free tier. Unfortunately,
the pill request to add that support to
Home Assistant core
was only merged eleven days ago and hasn't
been promoted from the dev branch yet.
So as much as I would love to
show you how we could do that creating
influx
with
Matt's actual data, unfortunately, that's not going to
be the
So what I am gonna do is run
through a slightly different example,
but go ahead highlight the function
that is needed to accomplish what Matt wants.
So I actually didn't realize this function existed.
I spoke to someone on our docs team
who was like, yeah, we added that recently.
And I was like, perfect timing. It was
a school day. Right?
Exactly.
All the time. I mean, Fox is evolving
so quickly. And in fact, I
think there's been 62
releases in the last twelve months. So continually
When
I was looking at it, it looks it's
a really nice expressive way to declare stuff.
It just it it felt really nice when
I was sort of, oh, it's just literally,
know, step, do this, do this, do this.
And it made a lot of sense.
Yeah. I really like it.
Yeah. It definitely champions the idea that working
with data is a is a transformation process.
And we'll take a look at that when
we write our our first query for sure.
But I found out just yesterday, we have
access to this over selection,
which actually allows us to filter all of
the values and prospect the timestamp on those
metrics,
and then filter them to the specific windows
that we wanna analyze.
Now because I don't have access to mass
data, I
do have access to something I've been working
on recently,
which is the tool called get series,
which will process all of the ref log
inside of your get repository
and store that in InfluxDB.
Now just so we have an understanding of
the kind of data that we're working with
here, we're gonna take a look at the
overview dashboard.
And this analyzes all of the commit points
written to InfluxDB,
And this is calculating an aggregate window, which
means it's breaking down all the commits
and two monthly
windows
that's specified by this drop down here.
And then it is doing a count of
the commits within that window. So we can
see here that the
09/01/2019,
there were a hundred and eight commits
to one or more repositories that were being
analyzed.
We have a total count and we have
the mean commits per windows. So on average,
every month, the repositories that were analyzed and
have her in 75 commits.
And because all of this is an influx
DB, we can actually do further breakdowns. Now
I'm only analyzing one repository, which is our
telegraph one. So the breakdowns are almost useless.
But we can also break it down as
well as commit to the number of contributors
on the project. We can see that telegraph,
you know, as a pretty consistent three to
five people
contributions.
We have release information and so forth.
Even breaks down the get series analysis,
the extensions
to try and guess which type of code
and files are inside the repository.
So we could track all of the modifications
to go files over time. We can see
markdown. We can see how the documentation
is evolving with the code and any other
languages that sneak ends. We've got some Tomo
comp files,
protobufs,
etcetera.
We could break that down even further just
by saying, show me all of the
markdown fails. Maybe I want to know who
writes the most amount of documentation in this
repository, and we can see the number of
commits in it.
So it's just a nice special way of
understanding what is going on within your get
repository.
But to come back to Matt's query then,
we click configure.
What we have here as our flux
explorer
kind of view where we can break out
the flux query and
get a real time visualization of what's going
on.
So if we just comment out our active
window
group,
and we'll keep our filters in and we
hit submit.
We have something that is almost
unintelligible.
If we drop down to the raw data,
we can actually see
each of the commits,
the message that was sent with the commit,
and we can see who submitted the commit
and to what repository.
And then what we're doing here with this
flux security is first specifying where we want
to read the data from and Fox DB
to all data is grouped by buckets. You
can think of that as like a database
or a table
and, you know, your more general purpose databases.
We then provide a range. So we're using
the pay forward operator here. If you're familiar
with Alexa or f sharp, you might be
familiar with this. But it just means take
the result of this from function call
and pass that and as the first parameter
to arrange.
With the range, we can specify a few
named parameters here. So we've got the start
value and the stop value.
Now what's cool is that this will use
the variables provided by the dashboard, which gives
us a start and stop time range here.
Not only that, we could remove that and
use duration literals. And I could say, show
me one month,
one year and so forth.
Once we've pulled out all of the the
points from the bucket and that range, we
then want to filter it to only see
the information that is relevant to our query.
So here we're analyzing anywhere where the measurement
is to commit and the field is a
message.
There's something that Flux does that people normally
get tripped on up and normally get tripped
on at the start is that we actually
get something called tables back.
And you can see this number kind of
incrementing
on the left all the way up into
the hundreds now.
And that just means that we're getting
a few hundred tables back.
And that is based on the group key.
So by default, it's gonna grip at any
tag within the database, which is gonna be
the author,
I believe.
Which means if I come along here,
scroll down to number one.
We still got the author is the same.
What else is on the group key?
Let's go down a bit more. Keep going.
Alright. So oh, so we do have some
different offers, but the group key is different.
We're just gonna modify the group key anyway.
Doesn't matter.
Now these tables are great when you want
to be able to see at in fact,
let's
bring this group in. We're going to add
a column and we're going to actually group
by the author. So the field itself, it's
actually called author
email.
And if we run that again, we're going
to get less tables and just time it
will actually be tripped by the author.
We've got table zero is Daniel, who is
the main contributor.
We
go down to one.
I really hope we don't see Daniel.
Oh, we do, but it's a different email
address. Good.
I wonder if that's what I missed last
time. So
we modify the group key and we get
back a table per group, which is really
useful because it now means that I can
actually count the number of commits
by email address.
That's not what I wanna do right now.
So what I'm actually gonna do here is
I'm gonna flatten the table so that I
can do some analysis of all the commits
without any group key.
So if I group that now, we'll see
that we only have table zero with all
of the commits.
We then want to do something. So
did we cover your query,
Matt? Or have I just gonna skip past
that?
Think we briefly covered it, but it was
I was essentially looking to get
the
average humidity between
7AM and 8PM and 8PM
and 7AM or, you know, maybe 8AM like
a twelve hour period.
Basically to compare
nighttime humidity levels versus daytime humidity levels as
an average.
Awesome. Yeah. That is great. So
we're gonna try and do the same thing
here,
but we have commence.
Now I know that most of the contributors
and maintainers for Telegraph are in The US.
So we're gonna try and break down these
commits using the error selection function,
And we're gonna try and compare
UK morning and afternoon versus US morning and
afternoon
to see
how many commits we get across those two
different regions.
So what I'm gonna do is first just
to say in this as a base.
So Influx, I can take any stream of
tables and just store them in a variable
so that I can reuse them again.
And I'm gonna paint this base into the
error selection.
And we're gonna specify a start time of
9AM
and a stop time
of
none.
And what we want to do is then
aggregate window
over that,
and we're gonna do a count.
The duration that we want to use here
will be on a daily
basis.
So we're pulling out all the commits. We're
filtering to only those commits between nine and
twelve, but we are gonna calculate a daily
commit count for that. And we're gonna yield
this
to the graph as
UK
commits
like so.
And if we copy this, we can reuse
base only this time.
We're gonna see that The US starts today
around 4PM.
We'll count their commits until
till nine. That's about
oh, that's eight till one.
We're gonna do seventeen,
which is 9AM.
Excuse me. Reveal on how bad I am
at math
till noon.
If we go by San Francisco time,
using the same aggregate window and then yielding
as US
commits.
And if I run this,
we should
have lanes.
We do.
Okay. So let's not do a day
because there are gonna be days where there
are no commets.
So let's amplify this a little bit and
do a month by month breakdown
over the last
because the range here is 2019, January '20
'19 till today, we're talking eighteen months. So
we'll break that down into monthly figures.
And we get something that's just been smoothed
out, so it's not as jaggy.
And what we see here is that The
US commits are substantially higher.
And that kind of goes with our hypothesis
is that most of the contributors and maintainers
for the project are in The US time
zone. So of course, we're going to see
this purple line of The US commits being
substantially higher,
but some of The UK commits actually just
checked on our own zero to one or
two.
So that's how we can use the error
selection function within flux to break down the
commits or as it where the temperature and
humidity sensors
within mister Hubble's
tank.
Cool.
That'll make sense.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Alright. I won't save this.
So I will stop sharing.
We will quickly see if there are any
questions. I don't think there are. Is there
anything you would like to go over before
we finish up for today?
Not
particularly. No. It was
we're sort of going over yesterday to the
just the ability to pipe into different functions
to say, ah, give me the
and I want a window. Now give me
the mean. Oh, there's a function that combines
the two that says it's an aggregate window.
Just simplify it. It was like, that's really
nice. Like, this it was it was pretty
slick. No. This is just something that makes
it that little bit cleaner and simpler.
And having Yeah. I think one of little
bit of Alexa before. The the pipe forward
stuff was was nice to see. Like, that
was probably one of my favorite things in
in Alexa. Was just the ability to just
run through transformations, you know, do this, transform
transform transform.
It does make a lot of sense when
when working with data.
Yeah.
Yeah. If that's a model really well, and
it's the way that you would work with
data, I mean, if you're writing it down
or or any other kind of crazy math
that you were doing.
And I think what's really cool about flux
is that we have you Well, what I've
used it for there is to speak to
InfluxDB. They're actually data sources that speak to
my SQL, Postgres, SQL lite. I can consume
CSV data. So it's not you're not really
confined by you confined by using flux to
only data and and flux DB.
Lots of possibilities are still really early, but
I'm really impressed with what I see with
flux and the team is continually making it
better, which is great. That's cool.
Well, you know what? That was awesome. Thank
you for that introduction.
I think we went a lot deeper than
I was just better. I definitely need to
get a set up and start playing with
it because it just looks like so much
fun. So thank you for that. Really great
that you were able to share your experience.
Be careful you don't go down the rabbit
hole. I've I've gone I've gone too far
now. It's
I'm trying to work out what I can
and can't automate stuff that doesn't need to
be automated, but I'm like, no, but I
could do. I could do it.
Tell you what, we'll redo this session in
like six months and we'll see how big
I am and how much and how lost
you've gotten in the whole thing.
Let's do it.
Alright. Well, thank you again. My it was
an absolute pleasure and I will speak to
you soon. Thank you for having me.
Bye everyone. Have a nice day.